tomorrow Massachusetts will become the
first East Coast state to allow the sale
of recreational marijuana nine states
plus Washington DC of legalized pot for
adults though Vermont and Washington DC
have continued to bar sales and Maine
has yet to begin them marijuana is still
federally illegal and many
municipalities in Massachusetts have
banned or temporary temporarily blocked
the pot industry but Tony Tecopa
recently traveled to a city that's doing
the opposite Holyoke Massachusetts
hasn't been a boomtown since the early
1900s
when every single one of these abandoned
paper mills were still in business
there's a ton of space available we have
about 1.5 million square feet of vacant
mill space in a setting empty space yes
and those mills closed those jobs moved
elsewhere but Alex more so the city's 29
year old mayor has an idea for bringing
the jobs back and breathing new life
into these old buildings Holyoke is the
ideal location for the cannabis industry
in Massachusetts and Massachusetts
probably in the country yes so the paper
city will have a new nickname
yeah the rolling paper city Morris hopes
to attract cannabis companies looking
for the space to grow process and sell
cannabis perhaps even with a few
Amsterdam style cafes where people can
enjoy it too I think there's a big
stigma in the industry and a lot of
folks still have their head in the sand
about it just down the road he showed us
the first green shoots of his plan after
backing this politically how does it
feel to look at it in reality yeah I
mean it it's just affirmation further
affirmation 50,000 square feet of vacant
unused space is now generating revenue
jobs for the city a good problem for us
to have would be to run out of run out
of space and that would literally mean
millions of dollars and additional
revenue to the city this former mill
space is now operating as a marijuana
cultivation Center after a ten million
dollar investment by GTI a cannabis
company based in Chicago betting on a
wave of East Coast legalization
if Massachusetts becomes the mecca for
marijuana consumption on the East Coast
and Holyoke is the pot hub of
Massachusetts and this is really the
capital
of East Coast marijuana yeah where we're
standing wherever standing could be the
epicenter of East Coast marijuana
yes Peter Kayden's is director and CEO
he says this location alone will be
capable of producing 700 pounds of
cannabis a month that's enough for about
320,000 joints or nearly four million
buzzed customers a year so you put 10
million in and you'll get multiples of
that back I believe so yeah Wow
overtime yeah I want to be clear this is
not a get-rich-quick business you but it
is a get rich business I mean that's
good money these days the case for
cannabis legalization is well-known
Holyoke is a community that's roughly 50
percent minority mostly Puerto Rican
it's a community that has been ravaged
by the war on drugs instead of a failed
and costly prohibition with arrests
skewed toward minorities advocates argue
for regulated sales and taxes a record
64 percent of Americans seemed to agree
saying they support legalization
according to a 2017 Gallup poll up from
just 12% in 1969 but as more states
experiment the case against legalization
make it stronger is recreational
marijuana in conflict with public health
because a little bit too soon to tell
about the long-term ramifications of
cannabis do you feel like doing it right
in Massachusetts will be a model for
your industry across the eastern
seaboard yeah this is probably the most
critical market we're gonna operate in
why most critical because it's you know
the biggest opportunity from a
recreational perspective being in the
Northeast Corridor we got to get this
model right here because if you don't
get it right politically what happens I
mean we are plagued by stroke of the pen
risk in our industry we're all subject
to regulatory frameworks here we got to
be very careful and very thoughtful
opponents of legalization worried that
it will lead to more use and more abuse
a recent study in Colorado the first
state to legalize found that the top 30
percent of pot consumers drove nearly 90
percent of the demand alcohol gambling
tobacco is marijuana of ice industry - I
don't really see it as as such I think
there's community benefits as compared
to to other something says or other
industries one of those benefits was on
display just a room over where Novus
Garcia was working as an entry-level
grow technician tending to young
marijuana plants after temping in the
construction industry he thinks this is
the best job in Holyoke earning him $15
an hour plus benefits and room to
advance so you're at the beginning of a
process here that will result in six
foot tall marijuana plants correct
and then marijuana buds marijuana buzz
that hopefully are bigger than your palm
Garcia says he's excited for the future
not because he's a pot smoker but
because he's a Holyoke native just like
mayor Morse together they're rooting for
their hometown - boom again it's illegal
and people need to wake up it's not the
days of the past you know we're moving
forward Holyoke has embraced the
industry and we we acknowledge that this
is an economic development driver for us
for CBS this morning Saturday Tony -
copal Holyoke Massachusetts